[Music]
hey everybody so we're waiting for
donald trump and we're actually in the
middle of an extremely powerful
summers under uh summer thunderstorm
here in boston so it's
completely conceivable it's entirely
possible that i will lose power
and or internet at any moment so just
putting that out there up front
it is um it is very very powerful what's
going on right now
uh fox news's stream is like blacked out
they don't even have
i mean just really weird what's going on
the white house does say that the news
conference is starting
uh live streams starting soon as you can
see there so a lot going on
very very much going on and a few
different things that i want to
discuss with you today i do have one
super chat question which is if
democrats win back the senate should
they nuke the filibuster is it worth it
i've leaned towards no and i have some
uh clips about that that you can check
out uh but i
my my uh inkling
my preference has been for not nuking
the filibuster
that it is certainly a double-edged
sword which may you know it's sort of
like
um packing the supreme court uh which
also
may well uh backfire so i have a few
different things to play for you today
first just to kind of get us oriented we
again are looking at
um it's not even you know it's not even
5 p.m we're already at 53
000 new cases today and 888 deaths
florida hitting another single day death
record
and it's looking like we could be you
know 60 70 80
000 cases per day very very soon so
that's going on and it's very ugly and
it's not looking good
there is a completely whacked out video
of donald trump
bragging about his cognitive test to
this doctor on fox news and of course
trump forgets the name of the test when
he's bragging about his memory
let's just listen to a little bit of it
is is the thunder actually coming
through that's
interesting if it is yeah uh the thunder
is very very loud here
and wow i don't know that that's ever um
somebody heard it somebody didn't people
are lying okay very good
all right well you tricked me okay let's
listen to some of this so the last time
i was at the hospital
probably a year ago a little less than a
year ago i asked the doctor i said
is there some kind of a cognitive test
that i could take no he said that was
less than a year ago
because i've been hearing about it
because i want to shut these people up
they're made they're fake news they make
up stories i mean
like i'll do an interview with you you i
didn't say you can't ask me about this
you
i say ask me anything i did one with
chris wallace he was nice enough to say
he said i just want to tell the audience
there was no question
that's off bounce okay and he's a tough
cookie and it was a good interview i
liked it i enjoyed it
and it was good but i didn't say you can
all trucks backing up as usual around
the interview
we ask this you can only we have to be
sharp if you're in
the office of the presidency we have to
be sure
so they were saying all these different
things it was going all over whichever
stuck none of it stuck fortunately but
one of the reasons it didn't is that i
took a test
i said to the doctor it was dr ronnie
jackson now this is very weird because
trump said this happened less than a
year ago ronnie jackson's been gone
since april of 2018.
okay so trump supposedly took the
montreal cognitive assessment in january
2018 and within a few months ronnie
jackson was gone trump says
this all happened in less during the
last year it's weird because ronnie
jackson's been gone so something's not
right
i said is there some kind of a test an
acuity test and
he said there actually is and he named
it whatever it might be right
he doesn't doesn't remember what it's
called okay and it was 30 or 35
questions the first questions are very
easy now remember it's actually like
12 questions but okay the last questions
are much more difficult
like a memory question it's uh like
you'll go
person woman man
camera tv so what's funny about that is
the question
the words are supposed to be unrelated
and so trump is grouping words
so it's funny that he says this is like
a really tough question i mean
this is all crazy okay i don't even know
that i need to explain it
so they say could you repeat that and i
go yeah so i said yeah so it's person
woman man camera tv
okay that's very good if you get it in
order you get extra points if you
okay now he's asking you other questions
other questions
and then 10 minutes 15 20 minutes later
say remember the first question not the
first but the 10th question
give us that again can you do that again
and you go person
woman man camera tv
if you get it in order you get extra
points they give you a lolly if
you get it in order they said nobody
gets it in order it's actually not that
easy but for me it was easy yeah
and that's not an easy question in other
words
they ask it to you they give you five
names and you have to repeat them and
that's okay
if you repeat them out of order it's
okay but but you know
it's not as good but then when you go
back about 20 25 minutes later and they
say go back to that quote they don't
tell you this
right okay so then this
continued and trump uh as our friend
aaron rupar says
portraying passing a cognitive test like
he discovered the theory of relativity
take a listen you know
if you take this test we may have to
reveal that i said it's all right i mean
is it tough tell me about never heard of
it
and i got a perfect mark
and the doctors were they said very few
people
can do that very few people get that you
understand it's it's not that easy no
it's time
there were other questions tougher than
what i just did yeah like counting
backwards from 100 by subtracting seven
so then the doctor was interviewed today
on fox and friends and this is like the
cherry on top
and the doctor says the interview proved
that trump was really sharp that the
interview was a sort of cognitive test
can you imagine anything more stupid
so he discussed the issue of his own
clarity of vision and i did
in a sense that interview was a
cognitive test ainsley i have to tell
you
as you know he is extremely sharp on
every second
and he he did a test on tv where he
basically
you know went through how his how great
his memory is and what he said was
even even all of the major leaders of
the world angel you talked about putin
he talked about chairman chi
he said that whatever you think of them
they're extremely sharp
and we need a leader that has that level
of awareness and sharpness
and that applies to the election real
quick yeah so
the interview trump's demeanor during
the interview was proof
that he's cognitively very very sharp
we are in essentially the stupidest
timeline that i can imagine if anybody
by the way knows of a
um uh live stream right now that is live
in the room because the so this is the
white house feed
they go live at the very last second and
then this is the fox news feed and it's
blacked out or grayed out
so oh the hill okay let me look for that
real quick
uh the hill live
let's see
all right we may have to sit through
just briefly and add but i think we can
tolerate that
together as i like to say
um and let's see oh i'm in because i'm
in massachusetts i'm being targeted by
the ed markey campaign here
let's see okay
and are we live in the room we are live
in the room very good okay so this will
be better it will give us more of a
sense of what's going on
by the way thank you to richie cabral
richie cabral
has just signed up at joinpackman.com
and his new member number one today okay
let's see what we have happening via
super
chat i do want to say thank you to c oh
no i already did that one notorious joe
says hey dave i tried to call in from
orlando florida yesterday absolute mess
over here hope you're doing well
appreciate you taking calls anyway yeah
we've actually so when i used to take
calls
for the broadcast show we would get 60
70 80 people holding
and i can't possibly get to 60 calls so
we realized
we should limit the number of slots for
holding
so now we've limited it to 30. once 30
people since i only get to 8 to 10 calls
once we get to 30 lines occupied
it starts blocking people and it is a
little difficult to get through but
we do what we can you know lou sassel
says why does brian taylor cohen
get big names like kamala harris on his
show while you
settle for names like jesse lee peterson
well
i don't think jesse lee peterson has
ever been on my show i did his show and
then i uploaded it to my channel and it
got over a million views which is
beautiful
um but you know my audience doesn't even
really like
politician interviews we have a
relationship with ro khanna
so he's been on a couple of times and um
but
whenever we go through see here's the
thing it's a lot of trouble to get
senators on because the staff needs to
validate their own existence so they put
a lot of obstacles in and make the
person seem so in demand and
you know by the time you get them on
you've invested hours in the logistics
and then like
very few people actually are that
interested in it people seem to prefer
just me chatting about what's going on
so you know it's a strategy it's a
strategy
zachary prakowski says ronnie jackson
did rejoin the white house briefly in
2019 okay that's fair i don't know
whether he was actually
uh the person that would have been
testing trump cognitively at that time
but that's
that's a fair point if that's true zelda
freak says is the supreme court vote for
faithless electors to vote for their
state's popular
vote a preemptive step to block national
popular vote efforts
really a legal question and i'm not the
right person to answer that
steve leon says trump gets the blame for
federal covet failures but has nothing
to do with vaccine procurement and
logistics
isn't that hypocrisy you are better no
it's actually not hypocrisy steve
um so i mean listen what does trump have
to do
with states deciding to say everybody
wear a mask or don't state saying close
or not
developing a testing program and
distributing tests okay trump is
obviously involved in that what does
trump have to do with oxford university
develop
developing a vaccine these are two
completely different things
and it is not a double standard or
hypocrisy whatever
or whatsoever i would even say either
way
thanks to molly mack for getting the
youtube sub alexander
bralt brow says trump chose the words to
repeat and still struggled how is that a
sign of good cognition yeah it's not
obviously it's not thanks to dr coryum
for subscribing for the second month in
a row on twitch
at twitch.tv slash david pakman
you can now see on my youtube channel my
twitch stream from two days ago
getting a chess lesson from alexandra
botez who is one of my coaches for the
upcoming pog champs
ii tournament in which i will be
participating also the king
cappy on twitch with their subscription
has just triggered a hype train
yesterday we reached
a level of hype train we've never
experienced before
which is hundred and twenty percent of
level five
okay now if that means nothing to you
congrats you're not sucked into twitch
and that
you you may be better off as a result
but we did reach a 620
level five hype train yesterday which
can you guys hear that i mean these are
some very very loud uh these are that's
loud thunder at this point i don't know
if you guys can hear that
name withheld says every time he ties
his shoes it's a cognitive test he aces
it bigly
jack mccarty says when passing a test
for dementia is something you were
touting as a success we have really
lowered the bar for president
agreed very much agreed thanks to wooga
who has gotten us to level two from the
standpoint of hype
waffles giraffe says did trump get the
test in advance or send someone else or
maybe both mr t
please repeat these five words
corruption hooker fraud racism
baby yeah those might be those are
certainly linked words for sure
danny thompson says what if federal
unemployment is slashed
from 600 to 200 per week or if a second
direct check
is issued but eligibility slashed from
40 000 to 75 i think you mean from 75 to
40.
wouldn't that be worse for republicans
in november than doing nothing at all
especially in the suburbs you know danny
that's a complex question and i'm not
sure i'd have to think about that
a little bit um
graham taylor has grabbed a youtube sub
fred rogers has sent a very small cheer
on twitch
we are at level two but with zero
percent
which is sad carl says yesterday jimmy
door
said obama enabled trump sending troops
into cities
by signing the indefinite detention bill
in 2011. what's your take on that
didn't see it i don't see the obvious
connection
but i'm glad to have my mind changed
joseph
dinzes says i'm working for the census
and they made me sign an affidavit that
said i could not protest speak or
whistleblow against the government crazy
is that even legal i i'm not i don't
pretend to be a legal expert but i don't
know if that's even legal
thanks to the ripple for the twitch sub
getting us to
30 on level two of our hype train
breaker 19 says you could argue trump
pushed for vaccine research funding that
was in the bill
that which led to vaccine again i just
don't know how that
is leading to oxford university or
moderna for example
getting a vaccine out and i mean sir
listen
there's no doubt that the government has
decided to pre-fund the production of
doses before we know if the vaccine will
work
any sensible government would do that
and you know if that's what
if what we're saying is trump's doing a
good job because he agreed to fund
speculative production of vaccine doses
it's an extraordinarily low bar it's
almost like saying
if you can remember five words you can
be president because
multiple countries are doing that bill
gates five years ago said the trick here
is you've got to fund
product production of doses before you
know if it'll work
like if you want to say that that's
something good that trump did
okay i can't imagine anybody who would
not do that like even trump obviously is
going to do that
timmy lunsford says do you ever worry
about your mental health spending so
much time on trump
yeah so i basically only spend four days
a week talking about trump friday
saturday sunday
i'm off politics sunday late afternoon
i'll start prepping for the monday show
but i do like a full three-day break
uh from trump's stuff steve leon says
vaccine procurement and logistics are
the reason us will have more supply than
the rest of the world
okay so i just addressed that steve
thank you
uh bill kittleman says david don't worry
about trump is going to kill his own
base with this virus i hate to say that
okay thank you to light
chaser and sally net and bring da booty
who have gotten us to level three of a
hype train
over on twitch which is very very
powerful again yesterday we reached our
record of six hundred and twenty percent
on level five
six twenty level five is the most we've
ever done
dalbert leal says hey david love the dr
dicarlo
interview how do you maintain sanity
after thoroughly and logically
explaining things to people to no avail
again i just you know take three days
fully off from politics every week
tom hardy has subscribed at the soyboy
level donna williams says do you think
trump will be prosecuted for crimes
after he's out of office no i believe
that there will be
um uh actions against his business
probably for financial elements uh
financial misdeeds
but anybody waiting for trump to be
criminally charged i don't think it's
going to happen
sean m says david how does your
day-to-day sense of style compared to
your broadcasting wardrobe do you dress
more formally when not performing
no i don't no i don't um
brand it it's basically the same thing i
have a bunch of different shades of gray
t-shirts like this one
and then a bunch of button-down shirts
and those are the key wardrobe elements
that i'm dealing with
brandon humble says over or under five
press briefings
until trump says something completely
stupid and dangerous
and has to recancel the press briefings
i'm gonna take the
over i think it's gonna be over
um if you're just joining us we are
standing by for a donald trump
coronavirus press briefing
urgently waiting and of course as you
may know let's just see
we were at 53 000 uh about a few for 400
more cases
have just been officially reported 53
000 cases so far today 894 deaths
tragedy tragedy this is the urgency
right here
my friends uh i do have oh
from the standpoint of memes i do have a
few memes i haven't received that many
lately when i get them i'll put them up
on screen for you
let me see if i can get a better angle
on this one hold on and then let's zoom
a little
i got this one recently i don't even
know where this picture is from
uh after telling you about the 10 inch
zucchini
in his garden he gives you this look
yeah that was not a euphemism yesterday
when i said i have multiple 10 inch
zucchinis
in my garden it was perfectly accurate
and then a lot of them are very small
there's a couple micro zucchinis
micro zooks which are still growing and
i look forward
to showing those to you when they are
ready for harvest here's another one
and i again i don't know where this came
from after he tells you he came here to
chew bubble gum and kick ass and he's
all out of gum he gives you this look
i don't get it i just don't get this one
and then lastly
ever look up in the night sky and think
about the infinite number of galaxies
each containing thousands of stars in
each of those stars being
suns for planets in their own solar
systems and maybe those planets contain
intelligent life
ever look at this incredible vastness
and your place in it and think to
yourself what does any of this mean
absolutely nothing everyone needs to get
out and vote in november now that's a
message that i can get behind
i like that one that's a very good one
and i think everybody should uh
completely stand behind that
uh we are um about 30 percent into a
level
three hype train thanks to the
strawberry rodeo
jumping in as well as jp
de beast already exists oh boy
um yeah a lot going on there
let's see other super chats
says david have you talked about moving
the british open to turnberry love your
show man donating to the best cause i
haven't i mean
you know it's just it's it seems like
it's more trump corruption i don't know
what else to say about it
matthew towers has grabbed a youtube
subscription
dkn says who are you voting for marky or
kennedy and why so i was asked about
this yesterday i'm leaning towards marky
and um i i kind of went into detail i
also have a clip coming out about that
tomorrow
so i won't go into like a crazy amount
of detail about it right now
matthias germany says trump is always
late from the standpoint of time yes he
is
janelle says have you ever had a natal
chart reading
and if so what are your sun and moon
signs no i don't believe in that crap
i apologize uh but i don't i've never
had a reading done
and i don't um i don't plan to i if
anybody's offended by that i apologize
the blue noble says what i was saying
yesterday was would you like a dragon
fruit cutting to add to your magnificent
garden preferably a purple fleshed
cultivar
maybe but i don't know if you can send
that stuff to the mail through the mail
and you know i just i'm just not sure i
don't know anything about that
um waller is me says trump's base has
shown
evidence that they will never leave him
that gives him latitude to start acting
as if he is now
as he is now to possibly capture some
undecided votes
troubling oh legal eagle has excellent
video on legalities of portland i will
check that out
and breaker19 says did i watch aoc
destroy yoho on the floor i watched
about five minutes of it i don't know
how much longer it was but yeah it was
it was wild it was very very wild
let me say a few other thank yous um
alex pike has just grabbed um oh what
happened here
alex pike just grabbed a membership on
my website and his new member number two
i also want to say thanks to alexan
angiano
who is new member number three on my
website susan owens
is new member number four and
i believe that's it let me very very
briefly mentioned
this program is primarily funded by
people who grab memberships on my
website
okay that's joinedpakman.com we love
super chat we love twitch prime we love
twitch tier one twitch tier two twitch
tier three we love all of that stuff
membership on our website is is really
our primary funding source and we had
over 300 people who had to cancel
memberships at the beginning of this
month because of the virus
we know what's going on unemployment
economic devastation much of it optional
and that's sad so if you're in a
position where you can help us sort of
dig
out of that 300 member hole and we've
made about 180 or 190 progress on that
consider grabbing a membership at
jointpakman.com we do an
extra show every single day for our
viewers called the bonus show
on today's bonus show i told the story
from two years ago where my vegan
producer pat ford
ate a sour cream based sauce at a
team dinner that we had and he's denying
that he did it
i believe that he'd anyway so we talked
about that on the bonus show today
and actual relevant news okay so
you can sign up at joinpacman.com coupon
code 2020 now as you can see saves you
66
but before you do that there's another
coupon code an unpublished coupon code
july surprise okay all lower case
none of those big letters that trump
uses randomly on tweets
all small letters july surprise no space
it's an even bigger coupon code and
uh our goal is 25 website members
i very powerfully believe that we're
going to do it i really do
but the vegan drama on today's bonus
show
is not to be missed quite frankly and it
is the uh
it's the stuff of legends jordan haddock
love haddock says the anti-government
right is silent as portland
explodes yep i've talked about that
quite a bit
green party trevor says opinions on
twitter cracking down on q anon i didn't
know that they did
we're actually um in the middle of maybe
scheduling an interview about q anon
and um it is uh
it's going to be very interesting if if
it indeed happens so we're waiting on
that
uh i see a few people saying the coupon
code july surprise
isn't working okay so there's two the
two elements that are important for the
coupon code july surprise number one
it's got to be all lower case
and number two it's one word okay people
are signing up with it right now so it's
certainly working
thomas cornell just signed up in his new
member number five
with the coupon code uh so it is working
it's working trust me my friends it is
working very very much
people asking what's the plan for
twitch uh no particular plan i mean
we're close to 40 000 twitch followers
which is great
and just continuing to stream that's
really the plan
let's see here christian gaffield says
tip for american oh hold on
tip for american crew fiber hair gel you
told me what you use and it's perfect
okay back to politics
no no particular tips yeah people wonder
how is it that i'm able to keep my hair
under control and i mean to call this
under control is definitely
open to interpretation i use a product
which does not sponsor the show
it's called american crew fiber it's not
the cheapest product i think it's like
how much is it it might be 12 bucks for
like a two ounce thing
but uh you you basically what you want
to do is
why are we talking about this guys okay
we we all know how to use hair gel all
right let's
let's not uh divert here eric yup says
yo dave not sure if you remember me but
i graduated with you at northampton high
how fitting was it that you won the most
political superlative i did not i did
not actually win that
eric yup um i don't know if yep
is code for something i remember eric's
but i don't remember an eric yup
and i did not win most political
so um that i don't know if this is a
joke or what
khaled khawesley hawasli
khalid hawasley says david can you start
covering more on medical research for
diseases such as als
you covered the covet covet vaccine
research well
and i feel it would be beneficial to do
the same for terminal illnesses
okay yeah that's certainly something
that i can look into
um anahi diaz says generation
z here hello from ca david wish you were
president instead of donald well
i cannot be president of the united
states because i was not born
in the united states oh boy my phone is
blowing up people very concerned
about these thunderstorms that we're
dealing with uh
zachary foster says david despite many
studies showing reinfection
from covid is not likely fauci said this
recently as well as gupta
why are people questioning it i am not
sure about reinfection there there is
now
more being said about supposed
reinfection
and i think it's a very important
question which we need to look at and i
don't i don't want to say the wrong
thing i don't know the answer on that
right now quite frankly
thank you to shisa lion dog purple toad
tv
stoned noel sweet tooth meticulous 7
and he went to jared all of whom have
subscribed or supported over on twitch
zip j says thanks david i am also a
member do you think we will be getting
another stimulus check
i really don't know if you if you force
my hand and i have to bet on it
i say we do get a stimulus check but i'm
not really sure
the blue noble says you don't need to be
afraid of trump losing
you need to worry about the three months
he will be in power if he more than
likely loses yeah the two and a half
month
transition period is going to be scary
that's for sure
clayton sackett says if you didn't do
this for a living what other career path
would you pursue
non-political um it's a good question
honestly i'd probably be working in
finance that's where i was sort of
headed
in fact uh in college until i did a
couple internships and was like
what the hell am i doing um but
there's a good chance that had i not
started the show while in college
i might have just sort of unhappily uh
mildly happily continued down that path
glad i didn't
and and you know what in the end i ended
up doing a lot of the finance stuff
anyway i mean we raised
venture capital for the show uh five
years ago
we i went through that entire process we
expanded you know what we we did all
that stuff i then took the company back
private by that i mean you know i
regained um
i i regained 100 ownership of the show
and yeah i mean i've gotten to do a lot
of those things uh so
i i think that it's all worked out for
the best for sure
daniel benia or bonita as we say in
argentina
says oh another spanish super chat
gaucho
saludos paz versus mute understood
thank you appreciate that
thanks to cbd123 and wiz
for the twitch subscriptions let me
thank a bunch of people
i'm going to run through these because
we have a lot of very powerful
subscriptions coming in
let's see here we've got hold on a
second
ray satchel olivia finch
garo jensen sonia polster
janzki brett muraldo
hold on here rick perry oh boy that
can't be the texas
former texas governor jeffrey felt dona
condo
william needham danielle jones caridian
jessica russell
and yaram neitzel that is 13 wow
that puts us at 18 new members
incredible incredible at joinpakman.com
um we are 15 minutes late for today's
coronavirus press briefing just as a
reminder we are experiencing major major
summer thunderstorms here in the
boston area and it's conceivable that i
will lose power
and or internet during this stream
um where were we over here
john kurakawa says do you think trump
was a beneficiary of
jilane maxwell's alleged sexual
trafficking and if so will he pardon her
thanks for everything
so two clips on that on tomorrow's show
um i don't want to preempt myself
it was weird when a reporter at the
tuesday briefing called her jazlane
i found that interesting jay kidd says
david thanks for being my go-to guy
while working out yeah you know a lot of
people have told me that as they are
going now
not necessarily back to the gym but now
that it's you know nice weather
everywhere a lot of working out outside
with different elements of fitness
um the replacement of the podcast the
audio podcast for commuting
has happened with jim exercise i think
we would call it
uh and a lot of people you know you
don't have to be i mentioned this only
because a lot of people don't realize it
if you prefer like a long-form show
instead of the clips we put on youtube
the audio podcast is available for free
it's not commercial free but it's
available for free
you know on spotify um where else is it
uh
spotify pandora itunes google play
stitcher i heart radio all that stuff
you can have it take it with you and
a lot of people seem to be working out
to the show
some people using it actually is like a
sleep medicine which is a little bit
different um
where were we let's continue
sunel matwani sunil matwani says do you
think trump's new conciliatory tone
changes the poll numbers leading to
november i don't
i think it's too little too late but
we'll track it you know we'll see apex
says
who would win in a fight jenki euger
versus alex jones
well alex jones would play dirty is my
view
um and he's all hopped up on like that
silver solution and stuff like that he
might throw silver solution in jenk's
face
but i don't know i mean
that that's actually tough that's
actually tough um
height wise i don't think either is
particularly tall
uh weight wise you know there's a
question mark there
i'm not really sure i'm not sure mantis
jk
says finish what you were going to say
regarding your hair okay so listen
here's the truth about using american
crew fiber for your hair which is a
product i've never received money from
and has been my go-to uh product for a
very very long time
you what you basically want to do is you
get out of the shower okay
you do a little bit of drying you don't
want your hair dripping wet
you then put the product in and
comb the hair the way you want it and
then you don't touch it
okay it's like set it and forget it
you've got to do it you walk away
for my thick semitic hair i need to
weight about
90 to 120 minutes let it all kind of
settle and then after 90 to 120 minutes
you run your hands through it because
it'll have a wet look until you run your
hands through it and then that's like
the final thing
okay clip it ship it that's the clip
that's the highlight you'll see it on
on all of our platforms next week
shannon bennis says yeah but and it's i
mean listen if you don't have the thick
semitic hair that i have
you probably just only wait 45 minutes
that's the reality but i'm in a
different situation
um shannon bennis says speculate how
does trump band people to his will
is he that charismatic um
[Music]
i think whoa what's happening with that
flag there oh somebody moved it
uh how does trump ban people to his will
i actually don't know i mean sometimes
when you just are believed to be a
multi-billionaire
people just kind of do what you say and
don't really question it and i think
that's a big
part of it i don't think trump is
particularly charismatic
few other people to thank let me say
thank you to
where are we violeta carro
john schneider or jan schneider
we have so many european viewers where
it's i
it's like it looks like jan the american
woman's name but it's actually not it's
a european man's name so i i
i'm just going to yan john schneider and
marsha lance who are new members number
19 20 and 21
at joinedpakman.com looks like we have
some technology
being dealt with here and that's uh
interesting nonetheless
kevin thomasson or thomason says hi it's
sad to see trump and republicans kind of
not doing anything about kovid in sweden
we have it bad but it feels like
what where'd that go i apologize it
scrolled up
in sweden we have it bad but it feels
like we at least try to do something
okay yeah i mean sweden is having a fair
share of problems but yeah we
donald trump has bungled this so much
it's just absolutely insane
uh the main scoop podcast says thank you
for the continued laughs and solid
coverage of the briefings do you think
anyone will follow up on maxwell or
cognitive test
i i believe we will see questions about
at least one of those topics today
chris stultz says if you had no choice
and you were forced to defend yourself
how many 12-year-olds could you
successfully fend off in a physical
altercation
depends how big they are i've seen some
12-year-olds that are gigantic
um so it really depe i mean it depends
on their size
probably a hundred um
breaker 19 says could you name the
governor in every state and senators of
course not no
but not at all i'm more concerned with
the churning of big ideas than
memorization
the blue noble says imagine trump
rejects the election and has to be
dragged out by his ankles
pounding his fists like a toddler then
thrown into the reflecting pool yeah i
don't think it's gonna happen
i just don't think it'll happen the dark
half says thank you david smash the like
button yeah please if you are watching
on youtube i need you to absolutely
destroy that like button
there should be nothing left of it when
you're done with it and of course if you
are watching over on twitch
make sure to hit that follow button and
be notified of future streams
we um we are only 398 followers on
twitch from the nice round number of 40
000 and by the way over on youtube
we had an incredible day yesterday we
are
very close to 900 000 subscribers
uh on twitch which on youtube sorry
which is incredible
black and sprite says i'm in my garage
listening while working out
10 16 pm uk time or 2216
as it is known there love it andrew
smith proud to be a member
and support david pakman independent
journalism at its best thanks andrew i
appreciate that
sean mccracken says grateful for your
political coverage i used to live in
buenos aires wonderful place
please unmute my twitter running joke i
ask you daily very good all right we
will look into muting
diane marzini says what are your
thoughts on papizer stock
it's 40 bucks right now because you've
done so well with tesla
i don't know anything about stocks i
don't know anything about pfizer stock
so i have no opinion whatsoever
um simply none s
dixon says thanks for your work you sort
the day's politics so i can continue the
things i love
hard to stay positive with trump eroding
on our lives
daily kujbi
has subscribed at the beta level sean
mccracken says i forgot to ask you to
say hi to my mom
kathy she lives in the ozarks and
literally doorknocks for biden and did
for obama thanks david
uh very very uh good to hear
kathy thank you please tell sean to stop
talking to me about muting
on twitter but you're doing a great job
a pr says if it came to it do you think
the military would step in
end the nightmare and hand back control
yeah listen january if trump loses in
november january 21st he's no longer
president
it's that simple for me and you know
these could be famous last words i might
regret being so confident but i believe
if trump loses he will leave that's
going to be it
t stan has subscribed with twitch prime
and says thanks for all the great
coverage
uh saul bivian saul solbiven
has subscribed with twitch prime as well
semi truck driver you look like a young
howard stern baba bowie
all right leopard says you were so buff
you should be called david peckman
i like that that's not bad dominic
greer sent some kind of an emoji
matt chavez says i was told to listen to
q today and literally died i don't even
know what that means like what is q
who is q i really don't even get it
thanks to paul grignion for subscribing
on my website
gwen ford robert payton
faith and aaron hathaway and william
janke they are new members 22 through 26
today
at joinpackman.com very much appreciate
that support george says hey david are
you
a mate drinker if so any brand
recommendations no i mean
people assume i drink mate because i'm
argentinian i've never developed a taste
for it
i i've not i'm more about espresso based
drinks and tea
but i've never been a big uh mate guy
eric baker says i previously gave up on
these briefings but i'm kind of looking
forward to this [ __ ] show
yeah it's going to be wild today i
predict adrian benningfield says trump's
influence on people is probably due to
tv
tv is a big part of it for sure and
decreased attention spans
that chulo says so what's your take on
kanye west's comments on harriet tubman
i listen kanye west has said that he's a
bipolar
i think he clearly is someone struggling
with extremely severe mental illness and
i just don't think there's anything
there he's not really running for
president and he's very very ill
and i certainly don't want to make fun
of him and it's uh
he seems to be in crisis i don't really
know
that there's much more to say d money
says pineapple on pizza yay or nay
so when i was younger and i still ate
pork one of my favorite pizzas
was a pineapple and canadian bacon and
um
since i have stopped eating pork
although i accidentally ate pork in
martha's vineyard three weeks ago
uh store that story is on today's bonus
show as well we actually had a lot of
vegan drama today on the bonus show
um but uh yeah i uh
i have i am no longer in favor of
pineapple on pizza
okay here is donald trump let's switch
over to our preferred feed which is the
white house
feed uh we'll be about 10-15 seconds
behind but we're all much better off
with this feed for a number of different
reasons and we are going to listen to
what is to be said today listen to
questions hopefully some of them very
very nasty here we go
thank you very much thank you everybody
[Music]
oh god thank you we've had a tremendous
week
uniting the country in our fight against
worst weekend cases ever i've reminded
people of the importance of
masks when you can't socially distance
in particular
a strong message has been sent out to
young people to stop going to
crowded bars and other crowded places
yesterday we made the amazing
announcement
for our plans to protect nursing home
residents we're
working very hard on that we're doing
very well all over the country
and also about contracting with
uh pfizer we made a big big beautiful
contract with pfizer we think they're
very close but we have
a lot of companies that are very close
to produce a vaccine
and i wanted to come out again today to
share some
additional news with you this afternoon
my political team came to me and laid
out
our plans for the convention in
jacksonville florida uh-oh it's a place
i love
i love that state the drawings look
absolutely beautiful i never thought we
could have something look
so good so fast with everything going on
and everything was going well a
tremendous list of speakers
thousands of people wanting to
be there and i mean in some cases
desperately be there
desperately they wanted to attend people
making travel arrangements
you're literally dying to be at this
corona convention
signs the excitement we're really really
top of the line but i looked at my team
and i said
the timing for this event is not right
it's just not right with what's happened
recently the flare-up in florida this is
interesting
to have a big convention it's not the
right time responsible trump
it's uh really something that
for me i have to protect the american
people
that's what i've always done that's what
i always will do that's what i'm about
they said sir we can make this work very
easily
we have great enthusiasm incredible
enthusiasm sir
even the polls say about the most
enthusiasm
they've seen we can do this safely and
we can do it
responsibly i said there's nothing more
important in our country than keeping
our people safe
whether that's from the china virus or a
radical left
mob can you imagine you see in portland
where i want to thank
homeland security and others in law
enforcement so who thinks this will work
this contrite trump
days they went in and people were
out of control for 51 days a long time
and homeland security and other law
enforcement
with us went in and they've done a great
job in protecting our
property federal courthouse and other
and property most importantly protecting
our people
or the senseless violence that you see
in chicago or new york or
detroit a lot of other cities where so
many people are shot
and so many people are killed
people elected me to help and to protect
so i told my team it's time to cancel
the jacksonville florida component of
the
gop convention will be starting in north
carolina for the monday as
has always been planned we were never
taking that off that's remaining as it
is the delegates are going to get
together that's
where they do their nomination so the
delegates are
going to north carolina and they'll be
doing
the nomination and we're going to do
some other things with
teller rallies and online the week that
we're discussing which will be
really good i think we're going to do it
well and i'll
still do a convention speech in a
different form
but we won't do a big crowded convention
per se it's just not the right time for
that
i care deeply about the people of
florida and everywhere else frankly in
this country and even in the world
yeah this lady would be coming into the
state i don't want to do anything to
upset entry and even in the world
they'll be
doing very well very shortly we're going
to put someone to do anything too
of the country behind me and doing very
well you'll see that uh
the area that we're talking about is the
hot spot
you'll also see a lot of the country is
talking about there's no problem
whatsoever most of the country actually
so i'm always going to take care of you
so that
that's the way we're going to do it i've
spoken to
governor desantis and informed other
political leaders i want to
thank the jacksonville
community and its great mayor he's a
great great guy
really great guy they wanted it so badly
and
all of the other political
representatives in jacksonville and in
florida
and just very special people a very
special group
and they were there for us 100 but we'll
be going to north carolina today i want
to provide an update on the
actions we're taking to support the safe
reopening of america's schools oh no
parents around the world who have had
their children home
for the last few months of a greater
appreciation for the fact
that teachers are essential workers that
they're essential to our
children's future our goal is to protect
our teachers and students from the china
virus
while ensuring that families with high
risk factors can continue to participate
from home very important the american
academy of
pediatrics has released guidance
recommending that
schools reopen it said quote
lengthy time away from school an
associated interruption
of supportive services often results in
a
social isolation making it difficult for
schools to identify
and address important learning deficits
as well as
child and adolescent physical and sexual
abuse
substance abuse depression and suicidal
ideation this in turn places children
and adolescents at
considerable risk of morbidity and of
some cases mortality beyond the
educational impact and social impact of
school closures
there's been a substantial impact on
food security and physical activity for
children and for families
so that's very important and there's a
highway it goes both ways the national
education association recently stated
despite
the momentous efforts of educators
during the pandemic online learning has
never been
an effective replacement for in-person
learning
and support being at the school being on
the campus is very
very important one study estimates that
due to school closures last spring
the average student will begin this
school year roughly 35
behind in reading compared to the
typical year
and more than 50 percent behind in math
that's a big statement
how far is trump according to mckinsey
and company learning loss will probably
be
greatest among low-income black and
hispanic
students they're the ones that are hit
the hardest we don't want that happening
30 million american students rely on
schools for free and reduced meals
over 70 percent of the students who
receive mental health services do so
through their schools
according to hhs one in five reports
allegedly
having to do with child abuse they
have neglect and these are neglect and
neglected cases are submitted
by education personnel so
people in the education world on the
premises
will be the ones that report neglect
and other problems when they see the
children they know if they've been
neglected they know if they've been hurt
or harmed in any way
whether it's at home or someplace else
but they see this at school you don't
get to see that if you're not going to
school it's a big thing
fortunately the data shows the children
are lower risk from the china virus very
substantially
when children do contact the virus they
often have only very mild symptoms or
none at all
and medical complications are
exceedingly rare
those that do face complications often
have underlying
medical conditions 99
of all china virus hospitalizations are
adults and 99.96
of all fatalities are adults that means
that
children are a tiny percentage less than
one percent and even a small percentage
of one percent
in a typical year the flu results in
more deaths
of those under 18 in the united states
that have been
lost thus far to the coronavirus
many different names many many different
names
the life of every child is sacred and
must be protected
our sole focus is the health and
well-being of america's
children i have a very very special
person who loves children who's
who's uh i think one of the greatest
athletes of all time
a lot of people say the greatest pitcher
of all time
known as a relief pitcher could have
been whatever he wanted some people
he is the greatest reliever of all time
by far substantially more saves than
anybody else in fact
he got the presidential medal of freedom
recently
and uh he i'm reading off these stats i
knew he was the best i knew he was great
but i didn't know it was almost double
anybody else
but he's a man who loves children has
children loves children he's talking
about mariana
works hard with children we're going to
go outside and be with some little
leaguers
mariano rivera you know he's the sandman
right my wife said
darling why do they call him the sandman
i said you know
they play the song he just puts the
batters to sleep
this is a lie because melania doesn't
call him darling having mariano here is
a great honor thank you very much
talking about children in schools this
is crazy and uh
there's nobody that's done more than you
have thank you very much mariano
fantastic man given these considerations
we believe many
school districts can now reopen safely
provided they implement
mitigation measures and health protocols
to protect families protect teachers
and to protect students and we do have
to protect the teachers and the families
also we have to remember that all
families
should be empowered to make the decision
that is right for their own
circumstance this is especially
important if a child has underlying
health conditions or
lives with a parent or grandparent who's
at higher risk
in cities or states that are
current hot spots and you'll see that in
the map behind me
districts may need to delay reopening
for a few weeks and that's possible
that'll be up to governors
weeks the decision should be made based
on the data and
the facts on the grounds in each
community but every
district should be actively making
preparations to open
again the children obviously have a very
strong
immune system maybe even as strong as
yours
they seem to be able to fight it off and
not have a problem
so uh pretty amazing actually
great great credit our strategy to
safely reopen schools mirrors our
approach
nationwide uh-oh as we raise toward the
completion of a vaccine and therapeutics
the responsible path is to shelter those
at highest risk
while allowing those at lower risk much
lower in the case of
young children to resume work at school
and
as long as everyone practices vigilant
hygiene
and social distancing we want that a
permanent shutdown was never the
strategy which would ultimately lead to
greater mortality and irreversible harms
we don't want to do that
at the same time we have to get our
economy going we had tremendous numbers
issued yesterday housing prices pricing
of housing
up 21 the highest in history i still
don't understand how the highest number
doesn't sound good real estate housing
went up 21
today the cdc will provide additional
guidance for how schools can reopen
safely
i hope that local leaders put the full
health and well-being of their students
first
and to make the right decision for
children parents teachers and not make
political decisions this isn't about
politics
oh my god i just looked it up existing
home sales were up 21
obviously from a number that was incred
incredibly reduced prices weren't up 21
percent that would be insane
it was to provide 105 billion dollars
to schools as part of the next
coronavirus relief bill this funding
will support
mitigation measures such as smaller
class sizes more teachers and teacher
aides
repurposing spaces to practice social
distancing and crucially
mask wearing this money is in addition
to the 30 billion dollars we secured for
schools and universities earlier this
year
that money we have some is distributed
and some is not distributed
if schools do not reopen the funding
should go to parents to send their
child to public private charter
religious or
home school of their choice the key word
being
choice this is going to be a problem the
school is closed the money
should follow the student so the parents
and families are in control of their own
decisions so we'd like the money to go
to the
parents of the student this way they can
make the decision that's best for them
understand that the logistics of cutting
a check to parents for what would
normally go
from the state or city to a public
school
is a logistical boondoggle and it's i
mean you know
maybe will they get that check in 2023
and provide for their families the
council of economic advisers estimates
that 5.6 million parents will be unable
to return to work
if schools do not reopen this year
that's really the issue
tremendous problem it's a tremendous
problem
schools have to open safely but they
have to open
more than a dozen european countries as
well as south korea
taiwan and many others have already
reopened
well they dealt with the virus
intelligently and have almost no cases
we have seventy thousand a day unite
together
follow the best medical practices and
apply
common sense we'll continue to support
states and cities in the current hot
spots in the south
southwest and west the governors i know
them all they're all very very capable
they're doing a very good job they're
working
so hard you wouldn't even believe it we
have nearly 30
000 federal personnel deployed in the
states
that need assistance we're helping with
doctors and nurses
medical personnel of all kinds gowns
as a ppe update we're in close
communication with governors and states
we have supplies everything they could
possibly need
we're very strong in supplies remember i
used to say the cupboards were bare well
now the cupboards are the opposite
due to our historic efforts to increase
both the national stockpile and the
state stockpiles the vast majority of
the states have 60 days worth of
supplies on hand
and most importantly they have
ventilators because the ventilators are
very very hard to come by at least in
the past now we're making thousands of
ventilators a month
and supplying them in many cases to
other countries
for states that are making requests
we're rapidly delivering
in the last 24 hours fema has deployed
more
than 1.5 million masks upon request
1.7 million gallons love the gown and
600
000 uh well let me change that we've
created about 600 000 different
supplies we have 600 ventilators to
arizona north carolina pennsylvania
colorado idaho and washington i think
the number is
600 we're going to check that and we'll
give it to you in a little
while but we've uh we've got a stockpile
of
thousands of ventilators i think we've
sent out about
600 just recently the united states has
now conducted more than
51 million tests which is
more than any other country in the world
by far
roughly half of the tests are either the
rapid point of care test which frankly
solves a lot of problem and delay five
to 15 minutes instead of waiting
for service both ways in both directions
and then at the lab
but roughly half of them now which is a
tremendous
increase are five to 15 minute tests or
tests done in a
hospital where you get the results back
in less than a day
some cases immediately we're continuing
to
surge testing to current hot spots such
as miami and phoenix to
detect those with the virus and take
steps to stop
from spreading it further this is a copy
of the
map and this is uh you have it right
behind me that's
uh that's a map really very much
indicating where the problems
the united states for sure from that
it's in great shape
lots of it the northeast has become
very clean the country is a lot of
democrats up in that very good shape
other than if you look south and
west some problems that'll all work out
on therapies we've worked with florida
to ensure that
over 40 thousand vials of remdessevier
are arriving this week
it's a lot that's a really that's a lot
they're working round the clock to make
it it's had a tremendous impact
we've also shipped thousands of vials to
arizona california and texas over the
past two weeks
vials arizona is doing very well it's
heading down
numbers are heading down i think very
quickly governor's done a great job
they've all done a great job they've all
done a great job working hard
we'll continue to monitor the areas
rising and
with respect to cases and we ask all
americans to exercise
vigilance imagine insisting florida's
doing anything right
do whatever is necessary so we get rid
of this horrible
situation this horrible disease that was
sent to us by china
it should not have been sent they should
have stopped it they could have stopped
it
they didn't and the entire world has
gotten infected
and a lot of countries are going through
a lot right now this morning i spoke
with
president putin of russia we know and
they're going through a very hard time
with this
in moscow in particular i spoke to
the crown prince saudi arabia
they're doing well but they're going
through a lot everybody's going through
a lot yesterday i spoke to the heads of
four different countries
all four are going through a lot going
through a hard time
this could have been stopped it could
have been stopped quickly and easily but
for some reason it wasn't
and we'll figure out what that reason
was so with that if you have any
questions please
here we go from the convention were you
simply not convinced that you could keep
people safe at the convention
i just felt it was wrong steve to have
people
going to what turned out to be a hot
spot you know when we chose it it was
not at all hot it was
free cold and all of a sudden it
happened quickly it happens quickly and
it goes away and it goes away quickly uh
the key is we wanted to go away without
a lot of death
without a lot of problems and we're
learning so much about
the disease that's why we're we're very
cognizant of nursing homes we're
watching them very carefully and people
over a certain age
and especially people over a certain age
with diabetes or
or heart disease in particular but with
a problem
so uh we didn't want to take any chances
so we had a lot of people we have
the delegates want to be there we're
going to do a
fairly reasonably quick meeting in north
carolina the nomination will be produced
and then we'll announce what we're doing
how we're doing it whether it's
something that's done online i guess you
could call it online
whoa so uh there can nothing there could
be nothing like our last convention
unfortunately that was a great
convention and in a great place as you
know
we had a we had a going great time
but um it's a different world and it
will be for a little while we want to
get the world back
to what it was and i think we'll have
including
great job numbers uh including so many
things that are happening so positive i
have to say the
stock market is close to records for
nasdaq
it is it's already exceeded its highest
numbers
uh but we want to get our country back
to what it was
acceptance speech being from the white
house and are you worried we haven't
said that yet see we'll have that
we'll probably announce that over the
next few days this might dampen
enthusiasm for you
look we've done a great job we built the
greatest economy in the world
no we're nobody close not china not
anybody
china we had to close it we saved
millions of lives and we opened it but
we had the best numbers in history
that was weird i was like african
american hispanic americans
asian americans every group you want to
name what is that
young people without a diploma young
people with a high school diploma with a
college diploma anything you want to
name we had the best numbers
women doing incredibly never never been
a time like that
and we had to turn it off because of
what china did
we had to turn it off and then all of a
sudden
uh how strange now we turn it back on
and we're doing very well but it was a
very bad china speaking about china the
trade deal
means now we've got video but we've lost
audio
record corn day they purchased more corn
than any order ever
and that went on for two or three days
and soybeans and all but
it just means much less to me can you
understand that
just means much less to me please go
ahead what was the one thing if there
was one thing that changed your mind
about the convention
and did florida officials ask you to
cancel it
no they didn't we're dealing with them
but they didn't i would just say
safety just safety i just you know i
could see
uh the media saying oh this is very
unsafe this is i don't want to be in
that position
it's safety not because of the media but
that's what they would say
and uh we'll have a very nice something
we'll figure it out it'll be
uh it'll be online in some form maybe
it'll be
something even a little bit different we
have time you know we're talking about
the end
of august but uh i think it'll be
something that will be
exciting but there can be nothing like
having
25 000 people we had a tremendous thing
planned and a
tremendous convention planned in north
carolina right and it would have been
very good but a much smaller version in
florida
but then we saw what was happening
pretty quickly we saw that
that the virus was coming up that coast
so
the severity of the situation in florida
no i think it's going to uh come and go
it will i mean you take a look at some
of these locations
were heavily infected i mean to a point
where
deborah and i were talking that you know
when you look at what happened in new
york and what happened in new jersey and
other places
and now you're looking and uh so of
course
you know this is not trump prioritizing
safety it was becoming very clear
that it was completely irresponsible to
do this and it was going to be
politically not viable
many prominent republicans said we're
not going to go chuck grassley and
others so
he really had no choice say we're going
to have a lot of people packed in a room
and then
other people shouldn't do it don't
forget we're talking about schools
and we want them to be vigilant and
we're saying open
and then we're saying here you have a
big room but i also if you notice i said
where bars are crowded where other
things are crowded well there's nothing
more crowded than a convention a
convention i mean you've seen them
and even though you try and keep people
away from each other it's just not that
kind of a thing they probably
can't do that it just doesn't work for
them so it's very hard so i think we're
setting an example by doing it is very
important
yeah john mr president if i could come
back to school
openings you talked about money that
congress is looking at to help schools
who want to reopen if school wants to
reopen but is concerned about
testing would you consider directing
some of that money toward testing for
either a school district or even
individual schools
because that's what it took to open the
schools yeah i think so
i mean a lot of people feel differently
about
testing we talk about it a lot when we
have
50 million tests plus and you know we
brag we broke the 50 million test mark
second in the world is india which has
1.4 billion people
and they had 12 million tests and other
countries that are very big had two
million tests and some countries
essentially only test if you're sick and
walk into a hospital walk into a
doctor's office or
you're literally really sick they
essentially don't do tests unless you're
sick
and i understand that too so yeah if
they feel that that's what they want
it's uh that would be fine you would
tell congress you would encourage
congress to pay for testing
i would if they want again we've done 50
million
tests there's nobody even close in the
whole world
you look at our mortality rate you look
at our death rate you look at
different statistics we're doing very
well so death rate
one death is too many this should never
have happened this should never
have been allowed to happen from china
also mitch mcconnell's office uh just
put out a statement a moment ago about
the phase four relief package cares ii
saying quote it's tailored precisely for
this phase of the crisis
yet it does not include your payroll tax
cut so do you believe it's perfect i'd
like to see a payroll tax cut i think
it's great for the workers the democrats
would never have gone for it they don't
want it they're not big into the workers
i guess
and based on that i told them last night
i told the republicans who have been
working very
hard on this i'll tell you and they want
what's right for the country yeah
and hopefully the democrats ultimately
will but i said i think a payroll tax
will be good but you're not going to get
it from the democrats we need their
votes as you know
it's not like you know we have a
majority but it's not if you're
interested in the payroll tax cut i have
an entire video as to why it's not good
you can check it out on my youtube
channel
so we're not going to get the democrat
votes on that so i'd like to see it i
think would be very good for the workers
but
if we're not going to get their votes i
guess we have to go on to the next thing
a payroll tax cut would have been very
good
and maybe uh maybe something happens
uh yes please um you talk about setting
an example
on jacksonville but i just wonder some
people are going to take away from this
the lesson that you're pushing too
far too fast it seemed for a while the
numbers were going up and jackson don't
think you're going to have a problem now
this comes up at a time you're
pushing for schools to reopen we have
the opening of the
major league baseball season isn't isn't
the example of jacksonville that would
be pushing
too fast well baseball as an example we
were discussing it a little while ago
you're going to be at a
empty stadium i've agreed randy levine's
a great friend of mine from the yankees
he asked me to throw out the first pitch
and i think i'm doing that on august
15th at yankee stadium
and i say how's the crowd going to be
and you know
it's like you don't have a crowd there
is no such thing it's going to be
interesting mariano he's not used to
that
i've been at many games he walks in the
place goes crazy
uh i think it'd be just as good without
the crowd you were just born with it you
know some people are born with it
right it's talent i don't know if
naturally this is only for the baseball
players but i've never seen a pitcher
throw a ball where so many bats were
broken as mariano he's got the
all-time record i said how do you do
that he said parents
great parents when you get right down to
it right how do you do that it's called
parents
but but uh yeah i just just to finish i
think i think that
we have to all set examples i think
major league baseball is setting an
example by
you know playing to empty stadiums and
so are other sports you see that
now then they'll allow a certain number
in i see golf
now soon we'll be allowing people to
come in and percentages and all of a
sudden
we want to get back to normal the key is
to get back to normal because right
nobody wants to see this but i think
it's
really good that baseball is opening it
looks like football is opening
it looks like sports are opening we we
have it's a tremendous thing
psychologically for our country
and uh we're all we're all with it we
see
we're going to see right now some
beautiful young
little leaguers outside with a great
future ahead of them
they're already practicing on the front
lawn of the white house
and we're going to go out and say hello
to them and it'll be really great okay
how about one more
yeah please go ahead president trump um
the washington post earlier today
reported that one thing holding up the
gop uh coronavirus bill
is the white house asking that it
include language regarding the fbi
building in downtown washington dc is
that true
i don't know that they're putting it in
this bill but i know they want to have a
new fbi building
this one is something about a building
trump wanted to rent the effort it
really was never built to a very high
standard as you probably have heard
and it's got a lot of danger involved
and panels falling off the outside and
pieces of concrete falling off the
building
and they want to build it at the site
that they have it
they had options very far away from
washington
and i said to them frankly you have to
be near the justice department there's
nothing better than the site the site
they have now is better
but they were looking in sites in
maryland and virginia in different
places
but they would have been too far away so
i am i've been encouraging them to build
it and if you're gonna you have a choice
you can renovate the existing building
but it's not a good building
or you could take it down and build a
great building for the fbi for
100 years and have it be incredible even
with tracks on top they're talking about
you know we have because
fbi people like to work out a lot and
you could have literally
uh quarter mile tracks on top it's a
very big site very wide side
so i think the idea the best idea would
be to build a new building and that way
you have it for a long time renovation
can never be as good as a new building
in that case
i know they're talking about it whether
or not they put it in this bill or
someplace else but
the fbi needs a new building and we'll
get it done thank you all very much
thank you thank you very much thank you
everybody appreciate it
very very much and extremely extremely
powerfully
as we get close to the end of the
reporting day here uh
we just found 9 000 more cases while
donald trump was speaking and about 200
more deaths we are now
at 62 000 new cases today
um over a thousand new deaths sadly
tragically for the third day
in a row um let me see how is
massachusetts doing today
oh massachusetts still hasn't reported
we're being slowed today oh still some
states out
so not a particularly good day again
unfortunately my friends
um okay i am getting ready to uh shut
things down for the day if you are with
me on twitch
we are going to do something wild we're
going to raid a chess streamer who
doesn't even know me
ben feingold he only has 500 people
watching right now we have almost 2
000 over on uh twitch so i think that
if you join me in doing that it's going
to be extremely extremely shocking and
powerful for ben feingold
so join me there and if you were
watching on any other platform
that was a weird sound something's
happening here um
we are going to be wrapping up the
stream but i will be back with more
streams and much more
very very soon
you